no screws in those beers I can not deal
this foam I've never heard nose racing
what I've never heard that term okay so
really take this out of your face
there's always grace on your face Jesus
okay so then you take it and you just
like kind of find Greece I'm wondering
yeah which is like means you can drink
it sooner
hello today over time you have Francis
Cleveland wife of Grover Cleveland
so like basically Grover Cleveland gets
elected president and he was just like a
fat lonely man living alone in that
White House he was like okay I'm in a
very unique situation I'm not married
and like I needed shake this going to
like me the first lady rose Cleveland
Grover's lesbian sister was like let's
invite that and the Folsom lady to a
White House something so like um I went
to the White House
and everyone was like I think he's gonna
marry I'm the Folsom like that's going
to be the way this shakes down but then
you know grows like kind of saw Emma
daughter Frances beautiful 21 year old
girl and he was like how can I hit that
like it was romantic and like he wound
up being like let's just you and me take
a little tour of this White House
situation so like he took her out to
like some balcony that's all like
romantic or whatever and she was just
like look at this like look at this he's
like I live in the most expensive house
in America it's fabulous so they should
looked at it and it was like fabulous I
could maybe see myself being the first
lady but then Emma Folsom saw that like
Grover
Jokke on her daughter Frances like she
was like okay like I think you're about
to get with the guy that I like which is
like bogus you just like get out of the
country so she sends her to Europe for
like one year after her graduation but
unbeknownst to her own damn self
Grover Cleveland bro Francis like the
letter and was like let's get married
Francis like Brokeback like yes I will
marry you like it was one of those like
it was like a Khloe and Lamar sort of
nine-day wedding situation were they
like very quickly announce her
engagement Grover was like Francis I was
like we're gonna be the main bitch the
press freaked out so like Grover was
like okay well I will be fully committed
to a certain woman and I will be fully
committed to a one that's my husband
wife wait was it saying I didn't eat
today that's old I need to get some food
in you okay wait let's see you oh honey
cute I'm so proud of you
one place fragonard's pumpkin way thank
you thank you what do you think Connor
so like they did that and the press was
like hounding like it was the first time
that some president like married a girl
while he was in the White House she was
kind of like an egg girl like every time
she was on a magazine cover man would
move mad units like her image was really
exploited and people were putting her
everywhere everything from like
household cleaning products to like
small personal items like pill boxes
wooden things because they felt that
like yeah this girl will sell but she's
like whatever you guys can like
bastardize me and turn me into all of
these different commercial products
actually I'm a college-educated woman
I'm put together and I think people are
interested me and in a way that they
haven't been interested in other first
ladies and I'm gonna like blow that up
like if everyone's gonna be paying
attention to me let's make sure they're
paying attention to me for the right
reasons and by the way I would like to
be called Frank I mean you can call me
Francis you can call me Frank but mostly
Frank it's pretty cool a girl's saying
she wants me called Frank I mean that's
the thing is like she's a down-ass bitch
like she's like every single Saturday
I'm going to meet with the working woman
of Washington there will be lines
forming outside of the White House
Francis Cleveland like saw two young
girls eating omelet out of a dumpster
one day she's like that's not right like
this is not right as if she started a
charity called like the voting for
friendless colored girls I'm gonna say
like that's a brutal name for a charity
can't be quiet
wait ones are good okay that's good but
she had all this going on
so like rubber he was like I don't want
my wife especially a woman shouldn't
bother their head with politics but like
I especially my wife should not be
bothering her head with politics like
she Ola where's my lighter thank you
she was someone that said like yo okay
like yeah okay Grove's like you're late
you're telling me that I can't have a
political opinion or telling me what I
probably get these are my girls like I'm
gonna have these people I'm gonna shave
all of their hands when I hear their
thoughts and hear their voices and she
went out of her way to support one like
she was so charitable she never stopped
and on her very last day in the White
House 23,000 people came out to meet her
and she was like thanks so much she's
great I usually honestly I'm in love
with her like he was the greatest first
lady ever cheers Cheers today drinking
day drinkin
[Music]